keep users safe or be fined billions of
dollars the eu sets new rules forcing
tech companies to remove illegal content
how will the regulations work and could
they limit free speech on the internet
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad jim zhum it's being hailed as
the start of a new era for online
protection the european union has
approved rules to force big technology
firms such as google facebook and
twitter to remove illegal content if
they don't they could be fined billions
of dollars
tech companies lobbied against the
digital services act or dsa but eu
politicians finalized the details on
saturday after 16 hours of negotiations
the rules outline how companies should
keep users safe on the internet tech
groups will also have to disclose how
they tackle this information and
propaganda that effort gained momentum
after russia's invasion of ukraine
it's a wrap
we have the political agreement on the
digital services act
i have learned so much these two years
and the agreement tonight is better than
the proposal that we tabled
and what we have achieved
is that it's not a slogan anymore that
what is illegal offline should also be
seen and dealt with as illegal online
now
now it is a real thing
democracy is back
helping us to get our rights and to feel
safe when we're online
the regulations will come into force in
2024.
governments can ask companies to remove
content that promotes terrorism child
sexual abuse and commercial scams
social media platforms such as facebook
and twitter will have to make it easier
for users to flag harmful content
that'll also apply to e-commerce
companies like amazon for counterfeit or
unsafe products
companies will be banned from using
deceptive techniques to get people to
sign up for services repeated breaches
could see them banned from trading in
the eu
google responded by saying it'll work
with policy makers on the details
last month the eu approved separate
legislation to prevent anti-competitive
behavior by tech companies for example
sites like google will be banned from
favoring their own services and search
engine results messenger apps including
whatsapp will have to operate with
smaller platforms and it'll prevent
software being pre-installed on
computers and phones
tech companies say that could stifle
innovation
all right let's go ahead and bring in
our guests from brussels johannes parque
coordinating spokesman for the digital
economy research and innovation at the
european commission
from maastricht catalina gowanta
associate professor in private law and
technology at utrecht university in the
netherlands
and from paris thomas vinia partner and
co-chair of the global anti-trust group
at clifford chance law firm a warm
welcome to you all and thanks so much
for joining us today on inside story
johannes let me start with you today
just how will these regulations work and
also the fact that these new laws are to
be enforced out of brussels rather than
through regulators and individual
countries is that going to make
enforcement easier i think first of all
yes it will make enforcement easier it's
important to note that only the very big
platforms so if you reach 10 of
europeans so that is 45 million users
then regulation and sorry enforcement
will be with the european commission and
buses so a smaller platforms will not be
supervised for buses but it's of course
easier if you have
one set of rules for all platforms in
the eu and also a central enforcement
yes
catalina from your perspective just how
groundbreaking are these new rules and
regulations how how significant is all
this
um i think that the especially the dsa
if we're looking particularly at the the
discourse the public discourse around
illegal content um this is definitely
groundbreaking because the dsa is making
the invisible visible we have had a lot
of rules in the past that have been
applicable together with the e-commerce
directive which is the now predecessor
soon-to-be predecessor of the dsa the
digital services act um and um there has
been a lot of focus given to you know
what kind of content should be online
such as the fact that platforms should
be uh should should have a lot of
activities that are that they will be
responsible for in in terms of taking
down for instance terrorist contact con
content or child pornography uh so these
rules have already been there before but
what the dsa is now bringing to the fore
and therefore making the invisible
visible is that there's a plethora of
other rules that will be applicable at
the same time with the traditional types
of illegal content that we know and we
can see this in the definition of
illegal content in the dsa currently
which says that illegal content is
basically any kind of content that is a
violation of national or european law
thomas so now we have the digital
services act that has been approved
earlier this year the eu approved the
digital markets act that's meant to
tackle the market power of silicon
valley firms how far-reaching will these
regulatory actions be
well the digital markets act that you
just mentioned um
is rather revolutionary in terms of the
obligations that it places upon the
largest platforms which might very well
include a few european companies beyond
the
the american ones that that will
undoubtedly be included
so there will be some very far-reaching
obligations on those companies to enable
up interoperability for example with
facebook
apple will be required to allow
uses of different forms of in-app
payment mechanisms
google will have to rank um its search
results fairly
um without any preference for its own
search results so
quite a number of really very serious um
obligations in addition of course to the
brand new political agreement on the dsa
which has already been mentioned
johannes
these regulations this is all very very
big in scope um
how how will it be ensured that tech
companies are going to police themselves
yeah look i mean i would like to add
maybe one thing to what catalina said
because the dsa is not only looking at
the legal content but also at harmful
content so think about for example a
content that promotes
or kind of you know can increase ease
like eating disorders for example tick
tock you know these kind of
like young people following uh following
the feed and then maybe be inclined to i
don't know stop the eating habits that
is something that is not per se illegal
but it is harmful for the people who are
like for the young people especially who
follow this um so you will have uh or
not you platforms will do need a risk
assessment every year um and then the
risks that are identified that they need
to be actively mitigated and this will
then be controlled by the commission and
of course there will be fines for
example i mean the fines can go up to
six percent of worldwide global turnover
and in uh
i mean in extreme cases there could even
be a
ban of a certain platform so that is
basically the um the measures that we
have but it starts much earlier right it
starts and really going to the risk
assessment and seeing what are the risks
identified how are they mitigated and is
enough to be done or not
johannes let me just follow up with you
regarding something you said you're
talking about harmful content um
who who gets to decide what is
considered harmful content i mean i
realize that there are a lot of details
that still need to be worked out going
forward but but who's going to be the
arbiter on this
here look i mean one thing is of course
illegal content that's very easy to
identify because this is as catarina
said
defined by law now if it comes to half
the content it is really for the um
for the platforms themselves to look
into what is their their profile so what
is harmful or what can be harmful in
terms of of their content so there are
like four categories you need to be
assessed uh beyond edg content so for
example restrictions to freedoms or
harmful content that could for example
affect miners or um
or disinformation you know so
this but it really depends i mean let's
say platform that
is a pawn platform has of course a
different
risk profile then for example an online
marketplace where it's more maybe be
about counterfeit goods that may not be
let's say
dangerous but still not compliant you
know so it really depends on the
platform themselves to see what is the
risk profile that i have as a platform
and how do i need to mitigate this risk
catalina i saw you reacting to a lot of
what johannes was saying there so i'm
going to let you jump in but i also want
to ask you the same question i mean
who gets to ultimately decide what is
deemed harmful content and does that
bring up freedom of speech concerns as
well
absolutely so the the answer to your
question um actually is going to
determine the success of the dsa because
i completely agree with johannes so
there are a lot of different areas or
different types of content that the dsa
covers so illegal content you can look
at this also from a very uh from a very
technical perspective and you can see
okay is there a provision at national or
european level that is going to say you
can't have advertising um towards minors
under a specific age and if that exists
for instance if we look at the audio
visual media services directive then
immediately if a type of content is
going to be against this provision it
can be deemed illegal
then we also have the system this these
systemic risks so if a platform through
its architecture through the fact that
it amplifies uh types of content that
could have an impact on decision making
on the well-being of users or on a lot
of other aspects such as democracy
touching on what you were mentioning
freedom of expression and also different
um
political advertising freedoms then it
can be a matter of uh really trying to
investigate and this is where the
procedural aspects of the dsa come very
much in hand to investigate what exactly
are the systemic risks and how can we
hone them in the main problem here or
the key word here is going to be data
access and i really hope that in the
enforcement of the dsa and also in the
implementation so first of all in the
design of the um infrastructures that
are going to have to implement it there
will be a sufficient uh sufficient
attention paid to the fact that
data shared by platforms is not
necessarily reliable so we have a little
bit of a catch-22 situation we have seen
this before when facebook tried to share
research data and we've seen that there
were mistakes made and a lot of research
was deemed completely inaccurate because
of the fact that facebook data simply
was not good so catalina it sounds like
what you're describing you know is
rather complicated as far as you know
setting up procedures in order to be
able to implement this i mean do you
foresee this
going smoothly or do you think this is
going to get rather messy
um
it very much depends on also the
coordination of all of the stakeholders
that have already powers of
investigation so for instance if you
look at the national consumer protection
authorities because consumer protection
has been a very massive concern also for
the dsa johannes was already mentioning
um the fact that that you can have
various types of content for instance
like counterfeit counterfeit goods are
sometimes also considered to be products
that platforms need to look at um and
then remove um also from a consumer
protection perspective not just the
intel and the intellectual property
perspective but um
the problem here is that it very much
depends on how all of these
organizations that have a stake in the
implementation of the dsa and in the
enforcement of prior regulation will
come together um if we take there there
has been a lot written about um the
political compromise around the dsa and
for instance targeted advertising um
that that actually is meant to target
minors so who is a miner in which
country do we have which standards who
is responsible is it advertising is it
data protection a lot of authorities
nationally need to come into this web of
not only substantive rules but also
enforcement to figure out how exactly uh
to divide or to to coordinate the space
of the digital market because otherwise
there will be a cannibalization of
enforcement thomas from your vantage
point how do you think tech companies
are going to deal with these new
regulations do you expect that these new
eu regulations are going to face a lot
of legal challenges by big tech
well um
one could suggest that perhaps the
declarations of victory that have
surrounded this political agreement
might be a bit premature
in the sense that it seems to me at
least that there is a great deal that
remains to be seen about how
the dsa is enforced um how harmful
content as you suggest is is is defined
um
and how these um new rules will be
implemented by the the tech companies
i i do find that there is quite a lot of
vagueness um in
in the
new
uh proposed law because it's not yet
fully adopted
um
and it's going to be difficult i believe
for tech companies um to
know exactly what they have to do
and what they may not do
so um
so i think there's a great deal of
uncertainty about how this is how this
actually pans out it will require a lot
of good faith on the part of everybody
involved and we'll see whether that good
faith materializes and thomas just to
follow up when you're talking about you
know this great deal of uncertainty that
surrounds us are you talking
specifically about uh the digital
markets act the digital services act or
or both
i'm talking about both but it does seem
to me and i must say that my area's
antitrust of the digital markets act is
the one that i am much more deeply
involved in but it seems to me that the
digital services act
almost by design it seems incorporates a
great deal more uncertainty the digital
markets act will also have a great deal
of um
questions surrounding it about what it
means and what the companies who are
deemed gatekeepers have to do and what
they may not do
johannes how much momentum did the
effort to pass
this legislation gain from the fact that
there is so much disinformation out
there with regard to the war in ukraine
and also that there's so much
disinformation out there when it comes
to covet 19.
yeah i think these uh developments that
you highlight um they also highlighted
of course they need to do something and
they have influenced a little bit the
negotiations in a way that we
incorporated the crisis mechanism
because one thing is that you have
regular contacts or regular exchanges
and these annual risk assessments but
another thing is that you have a
situation that you could not preempt
like now the war
in ukraine and to which you need to
react as a platform and we as a
regulator would like to understand what
platforms are doing what they are seeing
and what they do to mitigate the risks
and and this is why this crisis
mechanism was incorporated now to to
allow these kind of attack um
conversations and and you know
cooperation on these issues but if i may
add another point because you you
mentioned the freedom of expression the
dsa and the defense is very important is
precisely there to ensure the freedom of
expression because the one thing is to
remove content another thing is to avoid
over removal so this is why for example
in terms of views need to be very
clearly written people need to
understand what they sign up to people
need to understand why content is
removed if it's removed and they also
need to have a means to address in the
future to very easily say i think
there's an over removal please reinstate
this content so um i think what we want
to do here is to really give and this is
what uh margaret verstaya said i think
also you know he reinstate democracy in
the online world so do not give let's
say
this question only to the platforms but
also to to a governance framework which
governs and the way this this works on
it so this is a very very important
point and if i can make a last point to
what thomas said on the
on
on where he said to us or maybe not
defined enough of course this is
rather generic law because it needs to
be future proof i mean we have nowadays
certain number of platforms that were
not existing let's say 10 years ago or
five years ago or you know and we do not
know what the existence five or ten
years from nowadays so you need to have
laws that are that are future-proof the
e-commerce directive that catalina
mentioned is 20 years old so you see and
we may and we hope that we will have
this lawn place for a very long time so
it needs to be
future-proof and the cover also at you
know platforms that will only emerge
from in the future thomas i saw you
nodding along to some of what johannes
was saying there it looked like you
wanted to react please go ahead
yeah i agree completely that precisely
defining for example what constitutes
harmful conduct is really just not
possible um because new kinds of harmful
con con two kinds of harmful content
will arise uh and it needs to be
future-proof so i don't disagree at all
with that but the fact that the
um
the con the content of harmful content
is so uncertain is going to require a
great deal of good faith on everyone's
side in order to make this work it seems
to me
catalina um you know
the the articles the the reporting about
about um what's in the dsa uh the
digital services act says that that it's
going to allow people to be able to
choose how content is presented to them
i want to ask you is it actually going
to allow people to to stop algorithmic
profiling that is set up you know to get
more engagement are they actually going
to be able to opt out of that
um so i think that there hasn't been a
lot of public discourse around for
instance targeted advertising and uh
paul tank for instance was an mep who
really has been speaking about this at
uh at length um we what we what we can
already see is that a lot of platforms
are already creating uh parallel
recommender systems so for instance um
instagram and twitter even tick tock
have that right now um the the there are
definitely def different types of uh for
instance for you pages or different
types of feeds and then some of them are
based on more um perhaps um the time or
or date related uh factors and some of
them are based on for instance the
people who you follow on a platform so
from that perspective you could argue
that already some there are being some
uh some some changes are already being
very visible
um now the thing is that
one of the major problems that i think
the dsa perhaps can start to tackle
but it is so complex that that
we still need a lot of other solutions
is the fact that the
the data
broker market is very opaque so do we
even have a map of really understanding
which companies are using uh the type of
data that is being collected also by
social media platforms which types of
platforms or marketplaces are not using
that um how what is the percentage of
the platforms that use that so all of
these questions remain still to be
answered because the the pace at which
the online uh the digital economy is
developing is incredibly fast and this
is why i completely agree with what
johannes was mentioning that we need
future proof regulation the question is
how do we draw the line between
not having too little content and
context and having too much as thomas
was mentioning because otherwise uh
sometimes we deal with legal uncertainty
even when future regulate future-proof
regulation is there um and the example
that comes to mind is the unfair
commercial practices directive
that has been and still can very nicely
tackle dark patterns which is another
type of
user manipulation that we see very much
quoted in the public discourse around
the dsa but if you look at the
definitions in article 5 for instance of
the ucpd and you see tests that are very
very vague like an unfairness test um
you still rely need to rely on a judge
to interpret that and if you don't have
clear interpretations for very specific
situations then the market doesn't know
what to do with that and we see this
very clearly with dark patterns catalina
i also want to ask you for a moment
about the another law that the eu
enacted the data privacy law called the
general data protection regulation you
know there's been a lot of criticism
that it has not been enforced vigorously
enough are you concerned that the same
thing might happen with the digital
services act
um i definitely see that we're moving
into an era of digital enforcement
digital monitoring and also market
surveillance done not only by the data
protection authorities whether at
european or national level that are
designed and uh and have the mandate to
implement and enforce the gdpr but also
with a lot of other agencies and a lot
of other authorities so i think that
enforcement is going to be perhaps uh
we're going to see more and more
enforcement in the future
the the question that i would like to
ask uh
also
perhaps for this discussion but also for
other debates is how do we ensure that
we have coherent enforcement across all
of these agencies that are stakeholders
in the digital market and that is the
million dollar question
johannes um there are tech companies who
say that these regulations could stifle
innovation what's your reaction to that
yeah if i could just quickly come back
to the enforcement because it's very
different if you had to enforce data
protection which is enforced not only at
the national level but also at the
regional level for example in germany
it's the regions that are in charge the
data protection offices or if you have
central enforcement and that comes back
to your first question the dsa will be
enforced for the big platforms about 45
million users by the commission and it's
the same is true for the dma when you're
with these people but the gatekeepers so
um that is a completely different
situation um
and i would also like to add one point
on the targeting because what the dsl4
sees is that users have an option to
indeed opt out and say look i do not
want to be targeted and i want a
recommender system that is not based on
targeting now you can of course um say
that is not very useful for some
services it is simply not useful but the
choice will be with the consumer and
then of course we have to ban for
targeted advertisement for miners and
for for sensitive data now on your
question um
the point of the dsa is to introduce
obligations that come with sites so size
matters if you're a small company uh you
actually find it easier because you do
not have all the bigger
the same applications of the big the big
platforms this is also one one aspect i
mean it is very important exactly um
that you do not stuff the innovation
this is exactly what this what the dsa
also the dma in a way
foresee that you have different
obligations for big players than for
smaller ones and the dma for example
gives
rights to smaller competitors to for
example use marketplaces to sell their
products to have access to their data
which they nowadays don't have so um
it's exactly the opposite actually it
protects the small competitors
thomas we have a little less than a
minute left uh let me just ask you very
quickly from your vantage point does the
eu have enough manpower to actually be
able to monitor and enforce the digital
services act and the digital markets act
that was exactly the point i wanted to
just raise um
both of these pieces of legislation
together
mark a a huge increase in the amount of
regulation in the tech tech sphere um
and i tend to doubt that there will be
sufficient resources um
deployed by the european commission to
be able to effectively enforce them
all right well we have run out of time
so we're going to have to leave the
conversation there thanks so much to all
of our guests johannes barker catalina
guanta and thomas vigne
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
muhammad jim joel in the whole team here
in doha bye for now
[Music]
you